there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people
to see if we could become something more
so when they needed us we can fight the
battles they never could
the end is near it could destroy life on
earth we're gonna need some help from
April 27 together Avengers join us once
and for all
join us mightiest heroes not today so
are you making your voice deeper no is
my voice so cool I'm Peter dr. strange
oh you should have made up names
um I'm spider-man then Avengers infinity
war people 27 hey everybody it's Charlie
marvel heard I had some different plans
for other infinity war videos so they
dropped a whole bunch of new footage
that people who are freaking out about
like literally every single screen cap
from this movie was in my mentions with
people asking about it so I'll address
all these different things because some
of them are a little more WTF than
others especially Thanos actually using
the Infinity Gauntlet and this isn't him
snapping his fingers it's him like
squeezing his fists to use the power of
the Power Stone so don't worry I'll
explain everything there is a new round
of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video but in addition to all this new
footage I also wanted to do some box
office predictions so I'll do that after
I talk about the new footage because I
think we all have some ideas about how
many billions in like multiple billions
of dollars we think that infinity war is
going to make so biggest thing first
Thanos is on that as guardianship
holding up the Power Stone and you see
all this purple energy around him that's
just the energy of the Power Stone
because of the number of stones that he
has in the gauntlet when he holds it up
in the air this seems like after he does
whatever it is that he's going to do on
that as guardianship lots of speculation
that this might be the death of Loki
like obviously you don't see anybody
around them there but there are a bunch
of bodies that were standing around the
Black Order when Loki was handing over
the space stone but he's already put in
the gauntlet at this point it looks like
what he's doing now is just destroying
what remains of the Asgardian ship now
there's no Heimdall
there's no Valkyrie what happened to the
other as guardians I know there's lots
of questions about that I think it's a
pretty safe bet that some of them
managed to escape and the real death
here like not to undercut any like
really emotional death would potentially
be Loki
the disciple portion of Asgardians are
able to bail before all this craziness
happens so they're still in Asgard like
Asgard is not a place it's a people the
people still exist so Asgard still
exists but when they do that montage of
all the phase 1 movies it's not fan os--
using the time stone or anything like
that hopefully that's clear because like
the minute he crushes his fist they go
into the montage so there were a lot of
people commenting about that that just
Marvel cutting a montage into the
trailer that's not an actual scene from
the movie you get a really badass shot
of Shuri examining the mine stone of
visions forehead I've already done a
couple videos about the prequel comics
for infinity war especially the black
panther stuff that happens during that
movie where they explain how she fixes
Winter Soldier why they have all this
cool technology in Wakanda that makes it
easier for her to deprogram Bucky's mine
even though it's like this organic thing
it's not quite the same thing as
deprogramming vision but that's
basically what's happening is is like
she's just trying to figure out how to
keep him alive and separate him from the
mine stone because Thanos is gonna take
it one way or the other and as far as we
know she's never encountered any
Infinity stones I know like before the
Black Panther movie came out people are
like what about the soul stone of
Wakanda Thanos walking through that
portal into Wakanda in that other
trailer I posted awhile ago sort of
throws water on that theory because if
he walks through that portal with the
orange soul stone in the gauntlet it
means he got it somewhere else not in
Wakanda you get a better shot of Proxima
midnight lit up by her staff here this
is probably from that fight with Scarlet
Witch you get this crazy shot of Iron
Man and star-lord and people were a
little confused this is one like the big
screen caps that people were sending me
this morning they're like are they
fighting what's going on what I think is
going on is that star-lord is in grief
someone has just been killed an Iron Man
is just trying to keep him from throwing
his life away by charging Thanos dead-on
it doesn't necessarily confirm that they
both walk away from this Titan battle
but I knew people have been wondering
about Iron Man dying because he gets his
ass handed to him by Thanos I think this
is backdoor confirmation that he walks
away from the Titan battle but still
open to speculation just seems like
another character big or small however
you think about them gets sacrificed to
the Thanos meat-grinder
in this big Titan battle
but remember characters are relative
like the characters that they kill off
might not necessarily be the characters
that you would expect like everyone's
expecting a list Avengers but do not be
surprised if they try to weed out some
of the secondary characters too like
people haven't talked too much about
some of the lesser characters but don't
worry I will do an updated death
predictions list when we get a little
bit closer I'm still waiting for some
more footage just like stuff like this
makes it a little bit easier to do that
like oh you know maybe Iron Man is gonna
be fine more funny moments with Thor in
the Guardians something happier you get
more of that funny spider-man moment oh
or using our made-up names but you get a
much wider shot and it looks like
there's this portal that they can use to
travel inside Thanos ship because you
see Iron Man standing up against it if
you've ever seen any of the Stargate TV
shows you can actually put stargates on
the ships so that when they're traveling
at hyperspace you can still travel
between ships that are in mid-flight so
it just makes it really convenient to
get from place to place a little bit
more of mbaku just part of that big
Wakanda battle
I don't expect too much from his
character but he was one of the big
funny moments of the Black Panther movie
so I think that they're trying to double
down on the stuff that people really
like do not be surprised if he gets a
couple funny one-liners and then there's
just a couple of cool shots of war
machine with his ordnance obviously
everybody gets a big suit upgrade war
machine might not look like he has a
brand new suit but this is different
from the one that he had during Civil
War you know obviously even though Iron
Man has the coolest suits war machine
always has the biggest loadout but
talking about box office predictions
this is gonna be the thing that like
every single person everywhere talks
about regardless of their comic book
knowledge or how much they like the film
how much is this going to earn biggest
movie ever will it earn more than Star
Wars Force awakens you really need to
separate this out into two separate
ideas how much money is it gonna make
total like how many billions of dollars
in how much money is it gonna make
opening weekend just to make this a
little bit easier I'm gonna talk in
terms of worldwide gross you look at a
movie like black panther that broke all
kinds of pre-sales ticket records right
now they're saying that infinity war is
out selling pre-sales records for the
previous seven Marvel films combined
including Black Panther right now going
into the movie there are twice as many
people that have bought tickets for
infinity war then bought tickets for
black panther and black panther open
world wide just a little under four
hundred million dollars just for
comparison's sake Star Wars The Force
awakens like one of the biggest movies
of all time open to a little over five
hundred million dollars worldwide early
prediction now infinity war opens just
under five hundred million dollars
worldwide now that's not the lifetime
gross lifetime gross I think will
approach two billion dollars if not
surpass it so just think about it this
way it's gonna make as much or just a
little bit more than Star Wars The Force
awakens total lifetime worldwide gross
which is about two billion dollars that
doesn't take into account any
re-releases either because what they
might do before Avengers four comes out
next year is rerelease infinity war to
say hey you know watch both of these
movies back to back even though
technically they're supposed to be
separate it's really like a Part one
Part two situation so you get a little
extra bump from that too but just let me
know in the comments you know really
easy question here do you think that
infinity war earns more money total
lifetime gross
then Star Wars The Force awakens there
was a whole bunch of other news that
just dropped that I had to postpone so
I'll try to get those videos out soon
secret wars Hawkeye all kinds of other
stuff going on leave your requests in
the comments below I'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Chris Flint is please private
message me so I can get your contact
details they finally started selling
those Infinity Gauntlet since tours so
if you've won a giveaway you should be
hearing from me soon
about giveaway related stuff so while
you wait for everything click here for
that funny behind-the-scenes video again
and click here for that soulstone
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys
you